[Musik]
wir sind heute zusammen der harris in
jork mein name ist mama ich möchte euch
einen new yorker fürchten
[Musik]
der new york sauer sind prinzip ein
bisschen sauer unterscheidet sich nur
mit gesang dahingehend dass es vor dem
gast gereicht wird noch ein schuss
bordeaux wein obenauf geflutet wird
dann legen wir jetzt mal los new york
sauer besteht aus fünf cl werben
2 el zucker sirup aus drei cl
zitronensaft
und gefriergetrockneten hühnereiweiß
ungefähren halten ist prof dann
schütteln wir die mischung
[Musik]
und dann gehen wir noch in schuss
bordeaux wein obenauf
es gibt dem ganzen noch so ein bisschen
farbe so leicht trauriges aroma class
spekuliert wird der new york sauer genau
wie der whisky sour mit einer
orangenscheibe und einer cocktail kirche
fertig ist denn jörg sauer sie zum wohl
[Musik]